so we're starting today with one of the
biggest stories of the weekend and one
that has led to all sorts of different
conspiracy theorizing even involving yes
the new owner of Twitter Elon Musk and
we will get to that but let's start with
what took place a horrible home invasion
involving a hammer attack on Nancy
Pelosi's husband Paul Pelosi in their
San Francisco home this was a trumpist
anti-vax anti-semite there is no doubt
about it no matter how much the right
immediately said we don't know anything
about the politics of this guy and then
when it became clear that it was one of
these conspiracy right-wingers that they
must be lies or the entire thing was
staged or whatever the case may be so
let's talk it through step by step the
accused Pelosi attacker spread Q Anon
and other far-right bigoted conspiracies
this is an individual
who broke into Nancy Pelosi's house was
reportedly yelling where's Nancy
ultimately in the middle of the night
attacked Nancy Pelosi's husband with a
hammer requiring him to go into
emergency surgery a horrible horrible
situation and the individual uh as is
written about by the LA Times in some
detail was in the world of far-right
conspiracies anti-Semitism hate and more
in a personal blog that he maintained he
included topics like the hollow hoax a
term used by Holocaust deniers he wrote
about it's okay to be white
he mentioned the far-right message board
for Chan he posted conspiracies about
covet vaccines and even the war in
Ukraine being a ploy for Jewish people
to buy land this is all extensively
documented by the LA Times he included
posts about Q Anon
he wrote that either Q is Trump himself
or Q is the Deep State moles within
Trump's Circle
the daughter of the individual told the
times her father wrote this stuff she
said they were reeling from the news
that he had been the guy arrested in
connection with the attack on Paul
Pelosi the motive has not been
officially revealed but it has now been
learned in addition to the fact that the
guy was walking around yelling where's
Nancy where is Nancy it appears very
clear that he was targeting Nancy Pelosi
there is another article from CBS News
suspect in Paul Pelosi attack had list
of targets law enforcement sources say
um they have not gone so far as to call
it a hit list but authorities believe
the suspect may have been planning to
Target others arraignment is expected
tomorrow authorities are taking their
time fighting federal charges because he
is indeed in custody
um the suspect planned to keep Paul
Pelosi tied up until Nancy Pelosi got
home
it is not a random act as is being
reported Nancy Pelosi was in Washington
DC at the time the alleged attacker was
in the house when Paul Pelosi was able
to dial 9-1-1 and police were indeed
dispatched the suspect was apprehended
will be charged with attempted homicide
assault with a deadly weapon elder abuse
burglary and many additional felonies so
what the fundamental thing to understand
here and this is you know
it's one when something like this
happens you will often see the side
I don't even want to say that when
attackers in these circumstances are
right Wingers you will often see right
Wingers come out and sort of condemn all
violence generically
and the problem with that is that it
ignores that there has been a concerted
effort here by the right to dismiss and
normalize and sometimes even encourage
violence you know the culture of
violence promoted by Donald Trump
encouraging people to rough up
protesters at rallies dating back five
six years saying he'll cover the legal
fees of those who beat up protesters at
rallies violent rhetoric of you know
knock them out knock them around this
type of thing not ever truly denouncing
violence that is uniquely right-wing you
know the vague condemnations of listen
I'm against violence and also the
January 6 protesters were completely
right to be there and protesting because
the election was stolen from them you're
not really discouraging violence when
you do that so all of those different
things
play a role in this and when you see the
normalization of violence from everybody
from Steve Bannon recently saying fauci
and his family are going to be hunted to
even candidates even Marjorie Taylor
green is uh on audio visual recording
talking about going after Nancy Pelosi
this is exactly what happens this is the
stochastic terrorism that I've been
talking to you about for so so long
Trump has four rallies coming up I
believe it's Thursday Saturday Sunday
Monday or something like that leading up
to the election
does Trump defend this guy or does he at
least minimize what this guy did to some
degree or does he play into the
conspiracy theories that we're starting
to see about I think it's about a 50 50
shot and the magats have been
threatening Nancy Pelosi for so long
um uh to to some degree uh saying that
it is logical that something like this
would happen because of all of the
horrible communist things that Nancy
Pelosi has done which he hasn't by the
way and you end up with this attacker
who is a trump supporter watched him
pool red Ben Shapiro liked what Kanye
was saying about the Jews subscribes to
Q Anon and on and on and on this is
expected this is what I and others have
been sounding the alarm about for so
long and how does how does Fox News and
right-wing media react
a combination of depravity and
conspiracy theories let's talk about
that next the David packman shows
longest running sponsor is blinkist the
app that takes thousands of non-fiction
books boils each of them down into an
explainer you can read or listen to in
15 minutes blinkist also condenses
episodes of popular podcasts into
15-minute explainers I've been using
blinkist for years to supplement the
books I read I love reading I I read all
the time but there's even more books I
don't have time to read and you can
often find those non-fiction books on
blinkist and consume the entire thing in
15 minutes my favorite new feature on
the app is blinkist connect which lets
you share your blinkist premium account
with someone else you basically get two
accounts for the price of one and then
you can also share blinkist books and
podcasts between users I have a joint
blinkist premium account with my
girlfriend blink connect lets us sync
together what books and podcasts we're
listening to on blinkist Sparks many
interesting discussions we just listened
to Robert Greene's the 48 Laws of Power
the new version Robert Greene super
interesting writer find his books
fascinating you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a premium
subscription at blinkist.com davidpakman
the link is down below